- [Instructor] All right,
let's say that we have
the function f of x and it's
equal to two x plus five,
over four minus three x.
And what we wanna do is figure out what
is the inverse of our function.
Pause this video and try to figure
that out before we work on that together.
All right, now let's work on it together.
Just as a reminder of what a function
and an inverse even does,
if this is the domain of a function
and that's the set of all
values that you could input
into the function for x
and get a valid output.
And so let's say you have an x here,
it's a member of the domain.
And if I were to apply the function to it,
or if I were to input
that x into that function.
Then the function is
going to output a value
in the range of the function
and we call that value f of x.
Now an inverse, that goes the other way.
If you were to input the f
of x value into the function
that's going to take us back to x.
So that's exactly what f inverse does.
Now how do we actually
figure out the inverse
of a function especially a function
that's defined with a
rational expression like this.
Well the way that I think about it is,
let's say that y is equal
to our function of x
or y is a function of x so we could say
that y is equal to two x plus five,
over four minus three x.
For our inverse the relationship
between x and y is going to be swapped.
And so in our inverse it's going
to be true that x is going to
be equal to two y plus five,
over four minus three y.
And then to be able to express this
as a function of x, to say
that what is y as a function
of x for our inverse we
now have to solve for y.
So it's just a little bit of algebra here.
So let's see if we can do that.
So the first thing that I would do
is multiply both sides of this
equation by four minus 3 y.
If we do that, on the left
hand side we are going
to get x times each of these terms.
So we're going to get
four x minus three yx
and then that's going to be equal to
on the right hand side,
since we multiplied
by the denominator here we're just going
to be left with the numerator.
It's going to be equal to two y plus five.
And this could be a
little bit intimidating
'cause we're seeing xs and
ys, what are we trying to do,
remember we're trying to solve for y.
So let's gather all
the y terms on one side
and all the non-y terms on the other side.
So let's get rid of this two y here.
Actually, well I could go either way.
Let's get rid of this two y here,
so let's subtract two y from both sides.
And let's get rid of this four
x from the left hand side,
so let's subtract four x from both sides.
And then what're we going to be left with.
On the left hand side
we're left with minus
or negative five, or actually
it would be this way,
it would be negative three yx minus two y.
And you might say hey where is this going,
but I'll show you in a second,
is equal to, those cancel out
and we're gonna have five minus four x.
Now once again we are
trying to solve for y.
So let's factor out a y here,
and then we are going to have y,
times negative three x minus two
is equal to five minus four x.
And now this is the homestretch.
We can just divide both
sides of this equation
by negative three x minus two
and we're going to get y is equal
to five minus four x, over
negative three x minus two.
Now another way that
you could express this
is you could multiply both the numerator
and the denominator by negative one,
that won't change the value.
And then you would get, you would get
in the numerator four x minus five,
and in the denominator you
would get a three x plus two.
So there you have it.
Our f inverse as a function of x,
which we could say is equal to this y
is equal to this right over there.